first you really need all your features
to be available and fully usable on the
mobile version if you try to guess what
content or features your users won't
miss on the mobile you'll probably get
it wrong it might seem logical right up
until the point where I try to browse
store inventory from my mobile device
only to find that feature is not
available secondly with two apps or
sites there's a natural tendency to
focus on one or the other and to get out
of sync between them
maintaining two separate applications
and keeping them fundamentally the same
is hard to do and finally there's the
problem that it's difficult to identify
when you really want the mobile version
my tablet for example has nearly as big
a screen as my laptop and it's actually
higher resolution than my laptop mobile
design is actually more of a spectrum
that spans all the way from low
resolution devices up into desktop
design at the very least there are three
simple rules if you want to offer a
mobile only site first you want to make
sure a user can still get to the full
site from the mobile site if they want
to in case you forgot any features
secondly you should put canonical URLs
and meta information this is commonly
done for search engine optimization but
it's also important to keep your mobile
site and your desktop site together
finally if someone links to a specific
page on your desktop site you shouldn't
transfer them to your top-level mobile
page you need to transfer them to that
specific page or its equivalent on the
mobile site it's really frustrating when
you get redirected to the top-level page